unglaublich aber wahr die spritpreise
bei unseren holländischen nachbarn
übrigens die sind noch hören ja das gab
es noch nie glaube ich das ganze hier
deshalb kommen immer mehr holländer über
die grenze zu uns nach deutschland um zu
tanken verkehrte welt wir haben uns an
einer tankstelle in gronau umgehört
tanken in deutschland für die meisten
ein grund zum heulen unsere
holländischen nachbarn können da nur
müde lächeln denn in den niederlanden
sind die spritpreise noch höher die
preise sie gehen hier so richtig durch
die decke diese kostet 25 cent mehr 13
sind es sogar 45 cent deutsche
spritpreise für holländer also ein
echtes schnäppchen in massen kommen sie
deshalb zum tanken über die grenze hier
in kona ja dass ich sie will ich in
deutschland und die regierung in holland
ja die machen nichts für die leute und
darum denken wir die hollande hier in
deutschland aber das ist nicht mehr zu
tun in holland 250 26 ist ungefähr ich
denk 40 prozent vom lohn was du bekommt
von arbeit geht es im auto deswegen dass
wir in deutschland hin gehen ja für die
preisbasis noch in holland so viel
teurer ist aber normalerweise danke ich
nur für 20 euro
aber jetzt dass dich ich war in der nähe
und ich dachte hier kein wunder also
dass der holländische tanktourismus auf
hochtouren an dieser mineralölkonzern
gebundenen tankstelle an der tankstelle
an der enscheder straße in gronau da
brummt es wirklich richtig eine schlange
hat sich hier schon gebildet in dem
kassenhäuschen ist tatsächlich die hölle
los da sind kassieren jetzt zwei
mitarbeiter der tankstelle im akkord wie
die pächterin uns gerade sagte habe die
schlange in den letzten tagen
tatsächlich bis hin zum kreisverkehr
gestanden die tankstellenbetreiber
stoßen bei solch einem ansturm
allerdings schnell an ihre grenzen und
wir haben letzte woche nur jeder denn
jeder also von hundert autos waren 95
niederländer
zweimal leer gelaufen macht dazu gemacht
kein sprit mehr
die mondreise in holland für diesel und
benzin vielleicht immerhin ein kleiner
trost für die leidgeplagten autofahrer
hierzulande